hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
aperio versa vesicles highly multiplexed
immunohisto
chemistry approach to drug discovery i'm
susie valdez of labyrinth
and i will be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots and brought to you by leica
biosystems to learn more
visit them at leica biosystems.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
might have during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
i'd like now like to welcome our speaker
dr michael johnson
the chief executive officer of physical
inc
for a full biography of our speaker
please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen
michael welcome you may now begin your
presentation sir
[Music]
well thank you for the introduction my
name is michael johnson and i'll be
talking today about leica's april versa
eight
and also visicol's highly multiplex
immunohistochemistry approach to drug
discovery
now before i get started i just wanted
to show our disclaimer here
so leica biosystems did not sponsor the
studies they'll be described within this
presentation
or the work behind this presentation
now to get started just to provide an
outline of what we're discussing today
the first piece is an overview on
visicol so you have more of an
understanding about what our company
does and how we interact with our
clients and how we provide contract
research services to our clients
the next piece will be background on
immuno-oncology and multiplexing talk
about
where multiplexing came from and why
it's important then we'll dive into our
unique approach to multiplex tissue
imaging which we refer to
as our physical multiplex
immunofluorescence approach
we're going to talk about a few example
applications about how we apply
multiplex imaging
and practice and lastly once we generate
a number of different imaging files from
slides how do we use those to actually
answer
questions during the drug discovery and
development pipeline
to kick it off our company visicol is a
contract research services company
that's highly focused
on imaging advanced cell culture models
and digital pathology
we see our mission as helping our pharma
clients and biotech clients transform
their tissues and cells
into large data sets using advanced
imaging and then mine those data sets
for something useful to help them answer
their questions as part of their drug
discovery and development efforts
we work very closely with our clients on
their projects and work on a number of
different key areas such as high content
screening
and drug discovery assays histopathology
multiplex ihc
and digital path tissue clearing and
confocal and white sheet 3d imaging and
then also
3d cell culture assay services we're
leveraging 3d cell culture models
and high content imaging to characterize
these models in their entirety
and today we have over uh 12 of the top
20 pharma companies
as clients i've worked on several dozen
programs for our clients and all
different types of disease applications
from
infectious disease to rare orphan
diseases all the way to cancer
and diabetes and everything in between
the way that clients work with us varies
a lot from clients to clients we're very
flexible in how we work with our clients
but ultimately our whole goal
in interacting with our clients is
trying to help them answer their
specific research questions
and generating data isn't typical or
focused on it's generating lots of data
but distilling that data down into
something useful whether it's a graph
a table or a report that allows them to
better answer
their research question and to move
their program forward typically with a
lot of our clients we're trying to do is
accelerate the time to market for new
therapeutics
or we're trying to help our clients fail
their drugs more quickly we don't want
to spend
resources on moving drugs through our
discovery pipeline
if they shouldn't move forward we're
trying to help clients fail faster
and also answer unique research
questions during this drug discovery
process
the way clients work with us it varies
from client to client
some clients will send us blocks of
tissue whether they're
paraffin embedded whether they're wet
tissues some clients will send us
digital files or hard drives if we're
just doing
digital image analysis and other clients
will send us compounds or antibodies for
full end to end in vitro assays we're
generating high content imaging data we
might be doing histology and multiflex
imaging
and then other endpoints such as elisa's
and qpcr
as well depending upon what the project
specifically entails
while our main focus as a company is
imaging we also employ a number of other
readouts for our assays depending upon
what our clients are specifically
interested in
but the whole goal for all this work is
a toner of a report that allows our
clients to be in a better
more informed position to make decisions
now multiplexing refers to the use of
multiple labels to look at a slide so
we're closely referring to multiplexing
we're not talking about traditional ic
we're maybe having two
labels per slide we're talking about
four or five 10 20
30 labels per slide and trying to answer
a lot of different research questions
all about one singular slide the
introduction of several
immunocollege therapeutics in the
marketplace along with our improved
understanding of how the immune system
interacts with disease
has prompted researchers to require much
more
complicated tools for how they study
tissues in particular
we don't want to look at just one immune
cell marker we want to look at two or
three we want to look at the interplay
between many different types of immune
cell markers
and then also secondary and tertiary
effects as well such as apoptosis and
cell death
and self proliferation and trying to
understand how all these parameters
change in the context
of how the immune system is interacting
with therapeutics and also how the
immune system is interacting with
infectious diseases as well which i'll
get to a bit later
so the case for multiplexing is we have
very complex research questions
and we're finally now in a position
computationally
we can take all that data from a slide
and actually process it and turn it into
something useful
multiplexing does not employ
traditionally a pathologist it's
employing computer algorithms to
actually take these large data sets
and distill it down into something
useful which i'll get to later in the
presentation
as well but some of the kind of
questions
that we're looking at which are quite
complex and challenging to understand
with traditional histopathology
and imaging are things like
understanding how effective t
cells are at infiltrating into a tumor
try to understand how t cells are being
activated
t-cell recruitment uh cancer killing
efficacy
we're trying to understand the
distribution of immune cells how they're
interacting with each other
where they are and what they're doing
and this requires looking at multiple
biomarkers at the exact same time
the traditional technique which i've
alluded to is immunohistochemistry we're
looking at one
maybe two maybe three markers per slide
but
deek involved in those can be
challenging and labeling those and
developing those panels can be pretty
challenging
so with traditional techniques we're
usually limited in how many labels we
can get from a single slide
now because of this limitation we've
developed in the
field a number of approaches for going
far beyond two and three labels
up to five ten fifteen 20 even up to 37
labels per slide
there's a category of fluorescence-based
approaches and there's also a category
of imaging mass cytometry based
approaches with fluorescence
what we're doing is we're tagging
antibodies with fluorescent probes
this allows us to simultaneously
depending upon the imager we're working
with
and the availability of epitopes and
antibody species
up to five to seven markers all the same
time
but we can go beyond five to seven
markers using a bunch of different types
of techniques that are out there
one of which which is our technique
which i'll talk about in more detail
allows us to strip antibodies from
slides such that we can label slide
strip the antibodies relabel re-image
and do that process sequentially
such that we can move well beyond five
to seven markers per slide
there's also bleaching based approaches
we're bleaching the fluorescence from
slides
which allows us to go ahead and have
multiple rounds of labeling
during that process we're still leaving
the antibodies behind
there's also co-detection by indexing or
fluorescent immunohistopcr
and there's also fluorescent
tyramide-mediated amplification
all these techniques have their own
unique advantages and disadvantages
some require specialized equipment for
processing and imaging
some require proprietary reagents which
are challenging to access
and challenging to adapt for your
specific epitope if it's outside of
commonly used
uh markers for these types of studies um
but typically it's relatively rapid we
can get about five to seven channels of
imaging data at 40 x
and about 30 to 120 minutes depending
upon how much tissue we have on our
slide
and we're able to get a lot of data from
a single slide using these
fluorescent-based approaches
scitov is a different type of technique
it also uses antibodies for labeling but
instead of being conjugated to
um fluorescent probes or secondary
labeling threshold probes
we're using metal ions that are
conjugated these are metal ions that
don't
occur naturally in the environment and
we're using mass cytometry to go ahead
and process these antibodies after we
deplete the tissue
so we're bleeding a small region on the
tissue or moving that ablation region
around the tissue
as a pixel and from that one micron
pixel we're able to generate
imaging data from a slide using mass
cytometry so
really cool technique for returning mass
cytometry data into
imaging data that we can then use to
process so we get to almost the same
result that we're getting from
fluorescence but a very different and
unique approach to do it
with this imc based approach we can go
all the way up to 37 markers per slide
which is awesome for a lot of research
questions we want to get lots of markers
but it tends to be a bit slower in image
acquisition compared to fluorescence
and we're also looking at a smaller area
typically on a slide because of how long
it takes
comparative fluorescence and our
equivalent
magnification for this approach because
of the pixel size or blading tissues
is about one micron so about 10x uh
magnification equivalent
of their balance technique though has
great uh
background noise so background noise is
incredibly low because of these metal
ions not naturally occurring
both these approaches are great for
multiplexing questions it really depends
on your budget
and exactly what your research question
is for which one of these works
best for your research application like
all imaging tools there's not one that's
best for
everything they're all unique to your
specific application
the approach that i'll dive into more in
this presentation is our physical
multiplex immunofluorescence approach or
vmis
for short which we use here as is a call
to help us address this
problem of moving beyond traditional
histopathology
now there's several multiplex uh
immunoprocess approaches which i've
talked about and mentioned
they all have their unique advantages
and disadvantages but they all get to
the same place
which is getting five plus labeling per
slide
we had busical though we wanted to
create an approach that was really easy
to use
and was not um did not require
proprietary labels we could use
any antibody that was already validated
in traditional histopathology
we wanted to create a technique that did
not require specialized tissue
processing
equipment we could just do it by hand
the bench top or we could use
prostate equipment if we wanted to speed
things up we want to develop a technique
that was compatible with any fluorescent
imager
and also wanted to make the technique
easy to develop
new antibody panels for and to be able
to be flexible
with existing antibodies that we've
already validated and
we developed this technique which we're
referring to as vmif and i'll get more
into it in a second how it works
and we only launched this platform in
late 2020 i've been using it with
several of our pharma clients for about
a year now through our beta testing
process but a very robust platform which
i'll dive more into the next few slides
here to give you a sense of the workflow
of this process typically we start the
process with
our validated panels that we've
developed most of these are focused on
immuno-oncology applications
or developing custom panels now with
this technique what we're doing is we're
labeling
three to five antibodies with daffy on a
slide
we're validating each one of those
panels individually
and then we've developed an antibody
stripping reagent that removes the
antibodies from the slides
so we're labeling a slide with three to
five antibodies with dappy for our
nuclear stain
we're then imaging and then we're
stripping those antibodies off of the
slide
re-labeling with another panel of three
to five antibodies with daffy
re-imaging and repeating the process
again and again so we can do two
three four five six panels sequentially
after each other
after one another and generate a hyper
stack of data
now during processing this slide might
move a little bit the sample might move
there might be slight changes and
swelling or shrinking of the tissue
and all those sections align them
manually
really isn't feasible so we developed an
elastic co-registration approach
we can take all those panels and using
dappy is our ground truth
we can realign all of those individual
channels
into one large hyperstack of data and
that allows us to create a composite
image of that
slide from all those different channels
even though we didn't take all those
channels at the exact same time so we're
using daphne's our ground truth
and aligning from dappy now once we have
this
image file one of the big pain points
that we ran into
was actually getting the data to our
clients these files are very large
in size and with folks working from home
with kovid
a lot of people don't have access to
strong enough computers or fast enough
computers to actually load these images
and open them a lot of folks don't have
their image analysis software on their
personal computers at home
and can't remote access into their work
computers actually open up these files
so getting the file to our clients was
always a challenge
for any imaging based data this is a big
bottleneck so we developed this platform
called bitslide
i'll dive into this more in a bit and
show a tutorial on this
but this slide is a cloud-based sharing
platform that we use where we can upload
the data
and then clients can zoom in they can
pan around the data they can annotate it
they can change the contrast they can
change all these different parameters
about the images from multiplex and also
bright field slide scans
such that they can actually interact
with the data and they never have to
download it they can look at it through
a browser on a tablet on their
smartphone
on their computer they never have to
download the data they can if they want
to but they're able to easily access it
and they can quickly say back to us hey
this stain doesn't look right or
we want to change this or that looks
great let's keep going on the project
so if it slides away for us to easily
interact with our clients and share the
data such that the transition
from starting a project to getting
results to our clients is much
faster and then lastly we have a suite
of
image analysis software that we refer to
as three screen
this is an internal software package
that we've developed it's not a sas
product that we sell
or license we use this internally and
it's a toolbox of
different tools for analyzing these data
sets so for quantifying things like t
cell penetration counting different
types of immune cells
all different types of questions that
relate to quantifying
features within slides we use this
software for and ultimately the software
is being used to generate our report
that's coming from each of these slides
which i'll dive into a little bit later
here
the stripping reagent that we developed
we are referring to is easy clear
this is an approach where we're labeling
slide in this case i'm showing just
a brain section with map 2 dfat and
dappy
we're labeling that slide we're
stripping off the
antibodies and you see this reduction in
fluorescence
and then we can go ahead and actually
relabel again with the exact same
antibodies in this case and show that
there's no degradation of the epitopes
the labeling is exactly the same there's
concordance between these two so we can
go
through this process many times we've
got to about half a dozen times if not
more per slide
depending upon the tissue and generate a
lot of labels from a single tissue
just simply by stripping off those
antibodies and re-labeling
again and again in between our imaging
mirages
the next technology behind this which i
alluded to was our co-registration
approach so these slides will be
slightly off from one another as well
the stacks of images
and it's crucial for any kind of image
analysis to be able to put all this data
back together
so all of our different channels line up
perfectly with one another
and the way we do this is this elastic
co-registration approach where in this
case i'm showing
in red here uh one set of dappy and then
green another set of daffy from a
different panel
and how we take this elastic
registration approach to align those two
data sets with one another
and then correspondingly all the other
channels associated with that panel and
dappy
are now aligned with one another this
approach works very well
and we employ this in all these projects
to give our clients a really crisp
image and set of data from their slides
covet of course has enhanced this but
the problems getting to data to clients
has always been there covert has just
made it much worse
based upon folks working from home with
slow internet connections
uh slow personal computers and lack of
access to
uh software to look at images this is
even worse for
lychee and confocal images which we're
building bitslide out to do
as well currently but this is a secure
encrypted
and permanently backed up portal for
data it's robust and it's served on
amazon web services we're working to
make it 21cfr apartment compliant
we can vol view full 40x imaging data
right on a web browser so you can look
at on your phone on your tablet without
ever downloading the data
it loads very quickly which i'll show an
example of in a moment
we can toggle channels we can adjust the
contrast we can annotate images and show
to someone else
we can share with someone else on our
team and we can also download the
screenshots
or the raw imaging data if we'd like so
it's a very extensive platform that
allows us
to easily share our data with our
clients which again is a major
bottleneck with these studies
so just to um to give you a view i'm
going to play a
an overview of bitslide and how it
actually works here and show some of the
functionality
behind it
now you're seeing here the interface for
bit slide prior to the screen there's a
dashboard where if you have a project
and let's say you have 30 or 40 slides
you'll have a view and a tile for each
one of those slides and you can click
each one and you can zoom
in and the corresponding slide name for
that slide will of course be the file
name for that slide
but in this case i'm just showing a
panel here with daffy granzyme b
cd3 pan ck and ki 67
for cell proliferation and we're showing
how we can turn channels
on and off we can zoom in and out and
even though this is on a web browser on
a tablet
i can easily load these images i can
easily zoom i can easily pan i don't
have to download the whole image before
i can get started
and the level of clarity and the level
of detail is
absolutely fantastic with this platform
so this allows our clients to just log
in say hey the pan ck isn't looking
great or hey this contrast needs to be
adjusted differently than how it is
right now
or they might say hey the dappy staining
like on this slide here is a little bit
too intense
let's pair that back and lower our
intensity for imaging of that specific
channel
we also have these toggle buttons for
annotating the slides
which allows us to go ahead and have
features shared between different
pathologists or different team members
and we can also open this up and then
share with other folks on our team we
can measure
specific features based upon the
metadata behind the actual image files
so it allows us to do all the things
that you expect a traditional viewer
with the added bonus of being compatible
with multiple channel
immunofluorescent data coming from
multiplex imaging
the vimf approach that we have it's
relatively affordable on a per slide
basis
uh ranges from a thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars per slide for five to
fifteen labels
the variation there is a lot to do with
the cost of the antibodies and what
specifically we're labeling for
and this is that 20x resolution of a
whole slide scan so we're able to add
many channels to a slide at this price
point and generate a huge amount of data
this is inclusive of sharing the data
and providing access and storage to it
as well
the throughput for the approach that we
have is we can do about a slide every
one to two hours so we can process
about 20 slides a day in practice so we
can do a few hundred slides per week
with multiple
slide scanners and really crank through
projects of larger scales
as they come to us resolution we can go
up to 40x but in practice usually we're
looking at 20x which reduces our slide
scan
time quite a bit and then labels usually
most of our projects i would say have
about eight labels but we can go up to
about 15 reliably with this platform
uh we've done projects with four and
five as well but usually around eight or
nine is a sweet spot for folks looking
at multiplex labeling
for more labels if you want to go 15 20
25
30 that's when we start to look at the
imaging mass cytometry based approach
we'll look at
lots of labels per slide instead of
trying to optimize an approach like this
for that it becomes more economical to
go after the imc based approach for tons
of labels per slide for us
the example application i was going to
talk about or one or two i was going to
talk about was work that we're doing
currently with hackensack meridian
health
through a grant with the bill and linda
gates foundation this is a project we
started
recently and it's aimed specifically
at tuberculosis so while we talk about
multiplexing using the context
of immuno-oncology infectious disease is
another huge area in which multiplexing
is highly
important allows us to really answer
complex research questions
so for tuberculosis this is a disease
that's been around
for a long time has always plagued
mankind
today it's more so of course in
developing nations and in 2019
unfortunately 1.4 million people died
from tuberculosis the impact of this
disease
is huge um the doctor lab is focused on
developing
rational drug regimens for treatment of
tb we don't have
great treatments today we have effective
treatments but there's still room for
improvement for
treating tb preliminary data has shown
that drugs differentially penetrate tb
granulomas
these are the survival niches in which
the bacteria live
and we need to be able to get into those
niches to actually treat the
tuberculosis especially in stubborn
cases
and understanding how drugs co-localize
with the various cell pipes in
granulomas
is important in ensuring that drugs can
access and kill
persistent mycobacterium tuberculosis
populations
within the lungs so really crucial
research questions understand
what regimens that we can adopt and
change to better treat these patients
with this persistent disease
for this project it's not even just
multiplex fluorescent imaging it's also
combining our vmif approach with maldi
so we're moving
beyond just one type of multiplexing the
two types of multiplexing and trying to
understand
not only what immune cells are there but
what's going on with the therapeutics
that we're dosing
up these animals with in this case this
is a rabbit model that we're working
with of course
um and we're looking side by side slide
that we're using for multiplex
immunofluorescence
with maldi and we're lining up those
data sets with one another
such that we can actually generate just
significantly more data
and we're also using lcm as well with
some of the
endpoints this project to generate three
different types of multiplexing data
per single granuloma that we're looking
at
and we're using similar co-registration
software to do with the maldi data that
we're using for fluorescence data
such that we can actually line up all
those data sets on top of one another
and we can click through just like i
showed with our fit slide platform
each one of those different channels one
of them of course is going to be maldi
and we're looking at lcm
as well so we have other channels in
addition to our fluorescence channels
we're able to get all that data into one
single hyperstack
to start understanding exactly what's
going on in that slide
by comparing multimodal imaging
approaches with one another
and using the data between those two
between those multiple multimodal
imaging approaches with one another
the workforce and image analysis once
we've generated this imaging data
is based upon the specific research
question in this case
one of our core questions is trying to
understand who is in the context of this
granuloma where are different types of
immune cells
where should they be where are they not
trying to understand how treatments are
affecting
the distribution of these cells um
distribution from therapeutics to
distribution from
each other overall population so
counting the cells understanding who is
there
and how the concentration of these cells
are changing as a function of treatment
location so there's a number of
different spatial
um and temporal spatial parameters that
we're acquiring from these granulomas to
try and better understand which of these
therapeutics are working
and trying to understand how it changes
these therapeutic regimen
therapeutic regimens change the
population immune cells
in these granulomas so we're trying to
address really complex questions
and for this research project it's
really open-ended so we're going
first to try to understand who is there
who is near each other
what are they doing and how these
populations are changing and then from
there we're inferring what's happening
with the immune cell population
and how we can improve our treatment
regimen for subsequent studies
with these rabbit bottles so this is a
really unique approach to understanding
how our therapeutic is
working and generating huge amounts of
data from a single piece of tissue
and a few uh serial section slides
the um the last application here i was
going to talk about is how we use
multiplex image analysis and
quantification in practice for
immuno-oncology
applications this is the most common
type of work that we're doing
in this space there's lots of tissues
that are being sent
our way from all different types of
studies but these tissues tend to be
precious we don't have a lot of tissue
and what we're trying to do is get as
much data as possible from the tissue
we're not trying to waste it for
traditional
ihc or h e we're trying to go well
beyond that
and get a huge amount of data from a
single slide so in this case here i'm
just going to show
a simple panel of five labels including
dappy
and in this case we have pan case we're
using pan ck to isolate
the tumble area from the non-terminal
area on each one of these slides
such that we can answer some questions
about t-cell penetration
into our tumor area which i'll get to in
a moment here
now for more effective immune
fluorescence uh self-qualification one
of the things we do for all these
projects and one of the things
in our standard report for all of our
clients is just simple cell
counts so in this case we're isolating
our stromal area from our tumor area
and then we're counting how many cd3
positive cells do we have how many cd45
positive cells
uh pd1 positive cells we have and then
the combinations of those markers
with one another and trying to
understand where are these different
types of cells
in relation to being the tumor being in
the stroma and how does that
distribution
change for every slide
for a project like this where we have
five labels that we're looking at
we prepare this report for every slide
and we can go well beyond this type of
report which i'll get to in a moment
but we're showing how many of each type
of cell that we have what is the total
number of cells
in our stroma in our tumor area on the
overall slide and then for each one of
those cells
what are they actually labeling for of
course this gets much more complicated
the more labels that we do
but this table output allows us to
answer a lot of fundamental questions
about what's going on
on that slide and then to take this a
step further what we can do
is start to answer more complex
questions about the kinetics
of what's gone on with this treatment so
in this case here
the dark purple area on the outside of
this
slide which is highlighted here is our
stromal region
and the lighter area which all of our
lines are pointing into is our tumor
region
and what we're drawing is for each one
of these t cells we're trying to
understand
how far is from the periphery and we're
inferring how far
have those t cells gone as a function of
what they're labeling for
this allows us to try and understand um
how the immune cell penetration changes
as a function of a label and for this of
course we're assuming that there's not
strong area right above the slide of
course that would ruin these rays that
we're drawing from the periphery
but this allows us to actually quantify
some of those kinetics about what is
going on with our penetration
of immune cells into this tissue we do
the same thing with 3d cell culture
models so we're trying to understand
in a high content high throughput in
vitro model how t-cells are invading
into a tubal steroid for example
we do the same exact type of analysis
whether it's on a slide or whether it's
a high content format
to understand how this penetration is
happening and the kinetics behind it
and just to show you an overlay here of
our raw data
versus what we're getting with the
penetration we can see um
for these we can see the ray and the
heat map of where these t cells
actually are over the slide that allows
us to see
um on our slide picture what's going on
with our t-cells the reason this is
important is we can actually share this
data with a pathologist
so that if we have an h and e stain and
an iec stain and also a multiplex slide
we can overlay if there's serial
sections these heat maps for our
pathologist so if the pathologist wants
to do the traditional
evaluation but also add in some of this
data as well
we can add heat maps onto their data
sets through our bitslide platform
such that they can also get some of that
data and understand within the
traditional pathological context
what's going on with our t cells and
where they are so we're able to do a lot
of different types of data manipulation
image processing and image
sharing such that we can also involve a
pathologist if that's required for a
project
for most of our projects we're not
typically working with a pathology team
usually it's quantitative uh image
analysis based
quantification for these slides but we
can loop in a pathologist and we've done
that many times for projects
where that's required and also we might
want to validate the results we're
getting
in immunofluorescence our college we're
seeing in traditional
immunohistochemistry
so there is an opportunity for that
depending upon the nature of the project
but most of our projects are using
quantitative readouts for the endpoints
and um again just to show the automated
cell counts and we can break this out by
tumble area
non-terminal area we can also highlight
proliferating regions or
non-proliferating regions of the
of the slide so we're using ki-67 as our
marker to do that
and that allows us to also go beyond
this and start counting
um cells in those different regions in
the tumor area
in a proliferating region near
proliferating region um there's a lot of
different types of questions we can
address based upon exactly what our
research question is
but the possibilities with this type of
analysis are really endless
for every cell that we're looking at on
a slide we have the x and y coordinate
for it
and we also based upon our
co-registration with dappy
we know what labels of that individual
cell
is lighting up for and we can use that
to answer all different research
questions so the possibilities are
really endless with how we use this data
for different types of questions and
again to show this
um in a couple different ways and we
usually for our reports we'll have a
couple graphs a couple tables
uh for our clients we can show
proliferating region versus non-slip
rating region
who's there what are they doing um and
then we can go
uh the next step here and compare side
by side with different types of regions
to the overall tissue
and understand how things are changing
as a function of where we are
within the tissue and this allows us to
really provide our clients a detailed
view
of the immune cell population how it's
changing as a function of treatment
and how it's changing as a function of
any parameter that they're interested in
and also how those cells are interacting
with each other so openly we're
providing
for our clients from this approach is a
way for them to
answer really complex questions we're
generating a huge amount of imaging data
and then from that imaging data we're
able to use it for any type of research
question that our clients have
to understand the immune system to look
at infectious disease or really any
application
the approach that we've developed we can
use with antibodies that have been used
in traditional immunohistochemistry
and that allows us to look at any kind
of research application
just um even outside of immuno oncology
we worked on several projects in other
disease contexts that have nothing to do
with the immune system we want to look
at
many labels on a single slide such as
neuroscience
where a lot of researchers want trying
to look at the complex interplay between
different types of cells within the
brain
so the flexibility and possibilities of
platform are really open
and if you have additional questions or
anything at all in the approach i'd love
to
love to answer that and with that i'm
going to open it up to the q
a portion of this presentation thank you
and thank you michael for that
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
so let's get started it looks like we
already have
some great questions coming in
our first question michael are cover
slips
used for imaging uh typically in
practice yes they are
but uh if there's a project that does
not require coverslips we can certainly
work with that but for the most the time
more processing with cover slips
thank you so much and does the price
include
antibodies and should we provide the
antibodies
required typically the price does
include antibodies we have a minimum
of 10 slides we process the reason for
that is if you have a project that has
let's say eight antibodies we're gonna
spend three four thousand dollars to
procure
materials so typically we have a minimum
but if some clients have antibodies
they've developed internally they've
validated they want to send
along we can certainly do that and
adjust the price accordingly but
typically we're including antibodies in
that price
thank you so much now our next audience
member wants to know how does the differ
or what are the advantages
compared to miltonia's maxima
i think i said that correctly sure yeah
with the
penny system and a lot of the systems
that are out there we get to the same
place i think with built-in systems you
can get to more markers per slide
and there's a few other systems out
there proprietary reagents and
equipment where you can do that as well
for our system we're using off-the-shelf
hardware we're using off-the-shelf
antibodies that have been validated in
folks labs before
but ultimately we get to the same place
they might be able to get more markers
per slide
i'm not exactly sure what their cost is
on a per slide basis
but the end result would probably be
similar to our approach
as our most approaches getting to the
same spot after they're completed
thank you so much and i want to thank
our audience members for these great
questions
coming in keep it up michael how do we
know
these immune cells did not enter from
above
or below those are good questions they
certainly could have
we're assuming they didn't but um there
certainly could be a stromal area
right above our slide and therefore
we're saying it went
50 microns and in fact it went one
micron so we're making the assumption
that's not true
and with larger sample sizes we can
average that out and see what it looks
like but um yeah that totally could be
true but we're assuming it's not the
case and we're not having like
slivers of tissue and right above it
there's stromal area so it is an
assumption for sure
thank you so much our next audience
member says first
great technique great talk
she wants to know could you go 60x or
more
we could we certainly could uh we could
also do confocal imaging
of these for a bit thicker sections we
can also do light sheet imaging
not a 60x but there's a couple different
modalities that we can take we can go
higher resolution if needed
the only problem there is it greatly
increases the file size
and increases some of the complexity for
processing and shipment of data
but we can certainly do it there are
some clients and some projects where
higher bag is required
but most of the time in practice we're
looking at 20x maybe 40x but we could do
it
thank you very much now is analysis
modules or software
created per client
typically no typically most of the
modules that we use have already been
built
we have a large toolbox of different
modules for different types of questions
but i would say most the questions that
were asked from our pharma biotech
clients all revolve around the same
types of principles cell counting
distances
colocalization um which are relatively
straightforward
uh modules that you'd find in any image
analysis software whether it's halo or
even an image j so pretty standard off
the shelf stuff that we're using for
those questions
thank you very much and again thank you
to our audience members we love the
participation
michael which tissue type do you use
is it the ffpe or the frozen
we can do either or we tend to get
better results with frozen but some of
our clients just have ffp
blocks and we can work with those if
there is a lot of background noise we
can try and mitigate that
we can try and choose channels around
that which might limit how many labels
we can get per panel
but that's something that we would
discuss prior to starting the project is
the exact approach that we would use
thank you very much now is this next
person says
so there is no tissue damage or for
consequent
staining when the cover slips removed
between the staining
so um there might be but it's not
significant and from what we've seen
of doing uh the same label multiple
times one after another and then
co-localizing that
we haven't seen changes in that epitope
um the process is reversible so we've
also done
follow-up traditional ihc and haven't
seen changes in those epitopes either
it's possible we have some damage but
we're not seeing it on a macro scale or
on the individual epitopes
and michael which imaging mass cytometry
is best complemented with vesicle is it
ion path or is it fluidized
um it i would say it doesn't really
matter um
in practice we might take a serial
section and
do fluorescence then also do imc
uh we could use ion path or fluidim but
it gets us to the same place but if
we're trying to get more
markers per slide we use either one of
those i wouldn't say one's
best thank you and how do you strip
antibodies and get sample ready for the
next round
sure so it's a simple process that we do
it can be automated but most of the time
we're processing samples
in batches of eight or so and we're
using
the easyplex reagents that we develop to
strip off
those antibodies at room temperature
simply takes about 12 hours for us to do
that
once that process is complete we've
relabeled we get them back on to the
the imager but most of them are done on
the benchtop and
small batches of slides depending on how
large the project is but it can also be
automated if we have larger projects
now our next question is about 80 slide
is there a minimum
order or cost per the av slide michael
we try to do projects with a minimum
order size of 10 slides
um it depends on the project so like a
three label project versus a 10 label
project we'll have different minimums
it really comes down to we don't want to
spend fifteen thousand dollars on
antibodies
and process one slide because then
you're paying twenty thousand dollars
per slide which isn't feasible
so it depends a bit on the uh the
project depends on the antibodies and
cells
and the scale of the project we don't
want to have a project that's incredibly
expensive for one single slide if it
doesn't make sense for the researcher
thank you we have a few more questions
from our audience members
what light sheet platform are you using
and what
clearing techniques are you offering
sure so we have several confocals in our
lab
which we tend to process about one
millimeter thick tissues or less on
in a high content setup but for white
sheet we have a movie spin from brooker
it was i guess made originally by
luxendo who's acquired by brooker
but we have that system in our lab we
actually started our company
as a tissue clearing company about five
years ago so a little before
clarity we developed a tissue clearing
technique called visicol histo
that we sell through a number of
different companies also through our
website
which is an amphipathic solvent-based
approach which is
really rapid and works really well but
as a company we will use any tissue
clearing approach we've used
really everything cubic clarity scale
cdb
um you know all the clear techniques
that you could possibly imagine we use
like all imaging techniques there are
some that are great for some research
questions and some that are great for
others
but we will employ really any tissue
clearing technique that is required for
a research question in our lab
but typically i would say we're using
our visicol histo approach
for whole tissues our physical histo m
approach for organoids
and then for whole brains we're looking
at fluorescence
plus and protein we might use one of the
aqueous techniques that's out there just
to really try and minimize
any shrinkage and also minimize any
quenching of fluorophores
thank you michael we have a final
question you can work
can you work with human and marine
tissues
yeah so we uh we can work with really
any tissue we've gotten projects with
all different types
of um of animals but it just depends on
the availability of the antibodies
what we like to have is our clients have
already validated antibody internally
they routinely use it in traditional idc
and we can adapt that into the the
project
um so yeah it's definitely compatible
with those we do need to have the
antibodies to actually go ahead and do
that
thank you very much and actually we have
time for one more question do you use
labeled secondary antibodies or are your
primary antibodies
labeled with fluorescent dye typically
we're conjugating the primaries
um that's usually the approach but it
depends on the panels and how large the
panels are we can do secondaries but
choosing the species and choosing how
those match up uh
can be challenging so it just it just
kind of depends on the um
the project um but yeah it just depends
we can use either or
michael thank you so much and actually
we have time for a couple more
are you also active within the european
academic servicing sure so we have
clients um big small huge pharma and
also academic and
ngos that we work with and that's uh
really international we
accept tissues we accept slides we'll
work with
companies and work with academics to
make sure we can actually get slides
imported in through customs
so usually we're getting tissues slides
we could get hard drives of data for
digital path only projects but it's
relatively simple to transport those
into work on those
we have a full histopathology core here
too so we can get blocks and cut
sections and
get frozen samples as well and cryostat
those so we can definitely work with a
lot of different types of researchers
because of that and michael what kind of
run control do you use for the multiplex
staining and what is your philosophy of
it
yeah that's a great question this is
something that we get from a lot of
researchers to try to understand how
we're going to validate the approach
how we're going to validate the labeling
ensure that as we're running these
assays that we're continuing to have the
same robustness that we typically have
so this will depend on the client's
preference for more experimental
projects i would say we have less
validation criteria
that are used but for some clients we'll
do is we'll get a series of control
samples positive negative control
samples
we'll run the panels on those and we'll
ensure that the labels that we're
supposed to see
are actually showing up and whether not
showing up they're not showing up
and then on a routine basis for our
instruments uh we're qualifying it we're
running through our iq oqpq process
and then if we need to projects we'll go
ahead and rerun control
samples every time we run a new batch of
samples just to ensure the labeling is
what it's supposed to be
and it's being seen as expected but
those validation criteria really
are driven a lot of times from our
clients we will sometimes
start projects with off-the-shelf
validated panels or we'll be asked to
develop new panels and then through that
new panel validation process
the first phase of our project would be
to ensure that we can actually validate
those panels
and go ahead and image them and they
actually show up the way they're
supposed to so that's
typically how we start these projects
and regarding those
panels our audience member wants to know
do you supply the pre-optimized panels
and if so
are they tissue specific so the panels
that we have
that are pre-validated right now are for
human we have four different panels
right now
and we have all the validation criteria
that we've used on our website so which
which tissues we've used those in how
those tissues were fixed
some of our clients will say we have
that same tissue we
want you though to go ahead and
revalidate them in our tissue before you
get started
such that we don't run a project and the
label is not there the question is is it
really not there or is it the panel's
not working with this specific tissue
so that's something that we rely upon
our clients for
uh but yeah it just depends on the
client project
thank you very much now what are some of
the problems you run
into michael when developing new panels
for multiplexing
sure so this is anyone who's spent a lot
of uh bench stop time doing
uh immunofluorescence knows these
problems well we could run into
autofluorescence
uh we could run into a problem where we
don't have the right species for our
labeling or we have to have
many panels because we can't get four or
five panels on the same
we don't usually have problems with
conjugation and actually conjugating our
antibodies
but i would say it's usually a mixture
of um having the right control samples
having labels that show up the way
they're supposed to and then also just
making sure we mix and match the panels
the right way
designing the panels is crucial because
it allows you to reduce the amount of
time required for processing so how you
choose your antibodies
which ones you pair into these panels of
four and five labels
is really critical but um some tissues
we'll just have a challenging time
labeling there's a background
fluorescence or
not really seeing epitopes that we
should so we'll troubleshoot with our
clients but
that doesn't happen too often but when
it does we'll pause
interact with our clients and if we
decide that for a specific marker we
just cannot develop a panel for
we'll decide what to do from there and
make a decision before we jump into
processing dozens or hundreds of slides
for the client
thank you so much and we have time for a
couple of more how much variation do you
see in multiplexing staining
i guess it depends on exactly how the
question is
asked but what we've done for this is
we've looked at slides
and gone in with one label script the
antibody got it again
got it again and tried to co-localize
and validate that we're getting the same
standing intensity we're getting the
same exact colloquialization
time and time again and the concordance
that we've shown with that is
really good um but as far as variation
there might be
changes in intensity so maybe five or
ten percent changes in fluorescence
intensity
that we'll see most of our work though
we're doing co-localization and counting
and not relying upon actual intensity
so it tends not to matter that much the
actual image analysis
portion of things but there will be some
variation but it tends
not to matter that much in practice from
what we've seen
michael how do you remove the
autofluorescence
it depends on the tissue and it depends
on
how long it's been sitting for and what
type of autofluorescence it is
sometimes if the autofluorescence is
really bad in a particular channel
we can go ahead and actually subtract
that out so we know exactly which each
one of our
uh laser lines and our filter sets we
know exactly what things
should look like and based upon what
we're seeing we can actually digitally
subtract out
the the autofluorescence or we might try
one of our traditional
histological processing techniques to
remove the autofluorescence
uh chemically uh bleaching and things
like that so it just kind of depends
that is more of an issue if samples been
sitting for a really long time
we see it commonly with human brain
tissue that's been sitting for a while
and it's over fixed
but it also depends on what kind of
autofocus we're looking at
thank you so much michael and our final
question that we have time for today
how much do pathologists want to use
chromogenic versus
the fluorescent approach for multiplex
to gaining
so pathologists tend not to at least jam
our experience like
multiplexing period um especially when
you're talking 4 10 15 20 because you're
not using a pathologist
for the evaluation typically it's all
computer-based just because there's so
much data
that's being generated so from our
viewpoint i guess the pathologist
doesn't really have a preference because
it would be neither
it would be traditional histopaths and
looking at it and come up with a
qualitative interpretation
but they probably would be more
comfortable i would say with chromogenic
just because more
what they're used to but i don't think
they necessarily have
a preference for one or the other
michael this has been a great
presentation and i want to thank our
live audience it's been amazing
do you have any closing remarks before
we go
i just appreciate the opportunity to
present and if anyone has any questions
or would like to discuss a specific
project or chat further
we'd love to uh get in touch here so
thank you
well i want to thank you again dr
michael johnson for your time today
and for your important research and i
also want to thank labrutz and our
sponsor liko biosystems for underwriting
today's
educational webcast and before we go i
want to thank our audience again for
joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and
this webcast can be viewed will alert
you
on-demand
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time
take care and stay healthy bye bye
everyone